[Music]
okay this is gonna be fun it's time for
our seen and unseen segment and this is
where we expose what's really behind the
big cultural stories of the day last
night we blew the lid off this times up
initiative where Holly Hollywood elites
have band together to supposedly stop
sexual harassment across the fruited
plain
I said it was an obvious political
movement to organize against Republicans
including Donald Trump now a new
interview with a leading member of times
up meryl streep
may prove my point for all that is seen
and unseen I'm joined by managing editor
of EWTN news and Fox contributor Raymond
Arroyo and so Raymond what did old
Merrill pull off this well she didn't
interview with the New York Times this
is called self-preservation ala
Hollywood she's got a lot to answer for
Rose McGowan an actress who was abused
by Harvey Weinstein charged Meryl Streep
who worked with Weinstein on innumerable
films okay the Iron Lady the giver he
didn't only produce those films he
helped shape them he practically
directed them they were very close
McGowan and others say Meryl Streep knew
of this abuse and was silent well the
New York Times today pressed Meryl
Streep on this she got very testy she
gets very defensive very right very good
much she cut she tries to like well I
didn't know anything about deflection we
don't know everything about every called
him God
Golden Globes called him God in the last
Golden Globes she went after Donald
Trump without mentioning him by name
talking about the foreigners we kicked
them all out you'll have nothing to
watch but football that was before the
NFL tanked and mixed martial arts
she says this from her home in
Connecticut which are not the arts they
just disrespect invites respect violence
violence incites violence when the
powerful use their position to bully
others we all is she was attacking Trump
last Golden Globes so so where's what
she said yeah the New York Times today I
don't want to hear about the Silence of
me I want to hear about the silence of
Melania Trump what I want to hear from
her she has so much valuable to say and
so does Ivanka I want her to speak now
now hold the phone second Melania has
spoken as has Ivanka Trump didn't they
see the india trip what
the content of this interview is about
the silence in Hollywood last time I
checked Melania and Ivanka Trump were
not in any Harvey Weinstein films nor
did they work closely with them so
there's a lot there's a lot of
deflection going on here and this whole
times up movement as we discussed last
night it's a front group for a left-wing
activist this is Hollywood trying to
absolve itself that's guilt and silence
okay so they they they allowed this
sexual predator to roam free ruin
careers Paul Sorvino one of my favorite
actors loved him always have loved him
he's now what is it this TMZ MC caught
him and he's talking about his daughter
Mira Sorvino here's my question to Meryl
Streep where were you and Mira Sorvino
correctly this woman was an Academy
Award winner suddenly she can't get it
yeah Harvey Weinstein and Bob Weinstein
didn't want to get hired by anybody
right and so she they called out the
dogs on her and they said don't hire her
you know is lashing out now watch this
if I meet him on the street he oughta
hope that he goes to jail
because if he comes if we come across I
think he'll be lying on the floor
somehow financially that's a good
fella's all over again
further than that that was just the
opening but Sorvino is justifiably upset
they destroyed this woman's career
mirror so do you know where's the girl
power
so now it's all convenient they come out
with time's up time's up thirteen
million up time's up we're gonna help
the women who are driving tractors in
Nebraska if they don't have a voice Oh
get out you're all such fraud trying we
know exactly what they they covered up
and exactly what they knew because they
didn't want their own careers rocked and
they wanted Harvey's help it's an
attempt to collectively wash down hands
to the guilt and scapegoat on people
like Melania and Ivanka Trump sorry roll
on get out of town what about what's
going on with a bill we're in Key West
Anderson Cooper didn't know about the
pot being smoked he was shocked about
that right well Randi Kaye went to this
pot den in Denver this was the
centerpiece of CNN's New Year's Eve
coverage but CNN where does James Earl
Jones get to get to go to get his
voiceover back that's my question
Anderson Cooper was shocked by the
shocked I'm shocked they're all drunk
was he shocked by she ended up at a like
a paint
party where I guess this pot bus
ultimately ended up at a paint party
where for some reason I don't know I
guess people who have been riding around
getting stoned all night want to end up
painting in like dayglo colors look I
was talking like you don't know the
whole thing surprise me does anybody
else I gotta tell you surprise Jim I
love the giggle by the way how could he
be surprised Laura this is a celebration
like paint bus I mean can we lose the
lake I mean we're not Valley you know
well the hours of New Year's Eve
coverage on CNN like a celebration of
depravity how this reflects America I
don't know
bill we're poor bill wears down in Key
West he's getting felt up and groped by
guys Andy and animate wait we have it
clip watch this here is the drag queen
affectionately known as sushi sushi a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello middle America this is where it
happens in Anderson Cooper shocked by
the pop dance after that gambling in
this casino I like to remember when
Kathy Griffin stripped down and did a
sexual act wanting her back after what I
just said I hate to say it it could be a
step you need to smoke pot to understand
what's happening on CNN ever Raymond
thanks